good morning it's early right and you're
probably thinking what in the hell am I
doing here and let's be honest it
doesn't look very glamorous is it for
bare walls bleak yeah today you go to
transform this boring somewhat cold
shell into the most amazing unique
pop-up restaurant forget your
restaurants create something magical
good luck pop-up restaurants are one of
the hottest trends in the food world
they spring up in unexpected locations
cause a big storm and then disappear
overnight as the cash both restaurants
will have a 2,000 pound budget to split
between front of house for deco and the
chef's for ingredients
let's take 600 because I don't want to
be in a [ __ ]
good luck guys never shop any nicer
they've only got until 7 p.m. to trade
their restaurant from scratch up to 50
hungry diners who will expect nothing
but the best
so anything we have to score we have to
do we have to prepare to be a really
really new challenge I'm taking the
chef's of the markets and I'll be really
fascinating to see how this amazing
produce gets their creative juices
flowing and they'll have to really think
on their feet and adapt their menus
based on what they find
first up the butcher's what's going
through your mind cuz you've got to
start coming up main course one of them
what is gonna be okay you guys yeah I've
got to get that locked down yeah we
don't think about this when X 5 god
dammit society throughout this
competition chasm may have produced some
amazing food but some of it has been so
experimental it has missed the mark will
they be tempted to show up tonight or
will they rein in for their diners can a
portal but Peter and John ray are
tempted by real rolls-royce ingredients
beef but let the cook it sous vide with
a frog our parfait so with popcorn
there's not we have all about this sign
you can cook without a [ __ ] water
bath let's get that one yeah quite easy
so you gonna come out of that frame for
a minute and you go back to the
beginning and what these boys to forget
some of their wild experimentation
tonight can they cook something simple
and perfect with no frills oh this is a
valid form yeah we're going to go for
the really poor Reno's head chef Nevers
cooks fantastic Spanish tapas and pork
features heavily on their menu but I
want to see if she can go one step
further and do something extraordinary
for this one night only your carne yes I
need you as a main course start or he's
gonna be as a main course cuz there are
the cuts you've got the most amazing
loin I know I know but people love belly
pork love it you know pretty much
probably I'll get right so 14 of those
decision made pork belly a great cheap
cut but John rain Peter still can't
decide between flashy beef or simple
pork
this year and time is running out fast
hopefully it boosted slightly cure it
for it
excuse me change our change the studio
change
yeah we trigger the change border we go
back to Casa Mia roots go to port is
cheaper it's got great flavor we have to
work it harder working flavors work my
planet secure it
sorry the change might no be poor
where's it for for the ever since I said
let's go